bonsoir musique et cinéma seront
programme de culture première on
commence par le cinéma avec la sortie du
film le mafatais ou l'odyssée d'un
marginal réalisation d'olivier carette
musique je vous le disais d'abord avec
cette soirée poétique intitulé donnant
sur big nena réunissant trois noms
connus le guitariste patrick sida le
comédien gérald coupama est notre invité
la diseuse du mot sorcier annie d'art en
cours enfin nous irons à la saline dans
la fraîcheur des hauts avec la quatrième
édition de génération mannequin entre
autres invités pour cette édition
chanteur culture culture ou encore
simangavole nous avons téléphone dana
virama papa m'a dans ce magazine ce soit
la réalisation sonore est assurée par
pascal langlois les chansons sont
interprétées par michel picaud et pire
est pas cette culture première jean-paul
malades pour 100 km
avant de vous donner la parole cette
information pour les mamans sans louis
de rein marché de nuit spéciale fête des
mères demain de 19 heures à 23 heures
avec nos concerts de magie et le
concernant un spectacle de magie plutôt
qu'un concerne un spectacle de magie et
le concert d'aubaine de michael potvin
devant la mairie de la rivière voilà
c'est dit alors nous retrouvons galles
pour sa chronique hebdomadaire qui
reçoit beaucoup de coeur et vos idées de
sorties pour cette semaine eh bien j'ai
vu que dans votre soubie que ce soir y
avait un film il ya de la poésie est
légalement de la musique et je me suis
dit il faudrait quand même un peu de
théâtre pour accompagner tout ça du coup
je reviens à mes premières amours et je
vous parle de tête haute une pièce de
théâtre de joël jouanneau qui est mise
en scène actuellement à saint denis au
théâtre du grand marché alors tête haute
jean paul est offert aux auditeurs c'est
l'histoire d'une petite fille sans
identité et qui a été abandonné par ses
parents elle vit seule dans la forêt un
peu comme le matin tu es d'olivier
carette en revanche elle a une chance
extraordinaire c'est qu'elle connaît
absolument tous les maux de la terre
mais le problème c'est qu'à ligne en
leur sens exact du coup cette petite
fille va entreprendre un grand voyage
pour découvrir le sens de chaque mot en
en faisant l'expérience par exemple en
traversant une épaisse forêt elle va
comprendre le sens du mot peur et
l'histoire va continuer comme ça pendant
toute la pièce jusqu'à ce qu'elle trouve
l'essentiel à savoir son propre nom
george athor contes pour enfants
c'est un conte pour enfants mais avec
l'énergie et la fantaisie d'une alice au
pays des merveilles par exemple vous
voyez tout à travers les yeux de cette
petite fille vous voyez ces peurs vous
voyez ses joies ses étonnements mais en
même temps c'est une pièce aussi bien
destiné aux adultes qu'aux enfants alors
c'est quand le petit plus dans la pièce
à mon avis le peu plus le petit plus
c'est que ça va beaucoup plus loin que
le coup traditionnels le metteur en
scène à savoir sir et aelst travaille
beaucoup avec les technologies
numériques et il intégrait de la vidéo
dans son spectacle et croyez moi c'est
très très bien fait la vidéo est là
partition sonore nous permet en quelques
secondes de plonger dans l'imaginaire de
cette petite fille est de passer par
exemple d'un hymne dans l'univers mais
absolument effrayant à un espace
merveilleusement poétique je vous
explique tout d'un coup vous avez une
cascade qui y entrent dans le théâtre et
qui vient se refléter sur la seine ou
bien un peu plus tard vous avez une lune
qui vient se poser dans les bras de
cette petite fille autre chose à
signaler également dans ce spectacle
c'est que la comédienne a un jeu juste
et fin et du coup c'est cette
articulation entre jeu des acteurs
théâtre dont des projections vidéo qui à
mon avis dans nos à ce spectacle toute
sa poésie ainsi que du rythme et qui
fait qui mérite d'être vu du coup tête
haute mise en scène par cyril test c'est
une pièce de théâtre qui se joue au
grand marché ce soir à partir de 19
heures et demain surtout à 20h n'hésitez
pas à y aller alors une proposition
originale pour finir cette chronique
vous nous emmenez à l'artothèque de
sainteny exactement j'y songeais depuis
longtemps on connaît les bibliothèques
on peut emprunter des ouvrages et bien
l'art tout excité sur le même principe
sauf que là ce sont des oeuvres d'art
qu'on peut emprunter vous arrivez vous
prenez une carte d'adhérent et vous
pouvez choisir trois oeuvres qui vous
plaisent des aquarelles des dessins des
photos des sculptures et vous repartez
avec pour au moins trois semaines je
trouve cette idée géniale parce que ça
permet de rendre l'art accessible à tout
le monde et même de frimer un peu du
coup je conseille à tous les auditeurs
s'ils en ont envie d'aller faire un tour
à l'artothèque pour pouvoir emprunter
des oeuvres à l'artothèque 7,1 à ruth
paris/saint-denis du mardi au vendredi
de 9h30 à 16h
culture première
le film le mafatais sort au ritz et or
est ce le 30 mai est signée olivier
carette bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
bruxellois âgé de 46 ans passionné
d'image vous fait vos études de cinéma
en belgique vous avez déjà fait des
expositions chez nous avec des photos de
paysages et puis aussi de l'océan indien
vous avez à votre actif deux courts
métrages d'animation un court métrage de
fiction autoproduit il s'appelle sous
l'emprise des canes
beau jeu de mots en 2015 vous commencé à
écrire le mafate et c'est votre premier
moyen métrage de 53 minutes alors pour
ce qui est du synopsis l'histoire
rapidement d'un jeune marginal du cirque
rejeté par ses pairs et qui va connaître
l'avis sur la coop au port exactement
alors le décor est planté pourquoi
mafate et passe à l'asie aussi la hausse
mais je depuis 2015 je me suis
questionné sur la possibilité de faire
un cinéma
enfants tout cas de réaliser un film à
la réunion en utilisant les matériaux à
ma disposition c'est à dire la
géographie la culture et je me suis vite
intéressé à mafate et surtout à
l'histoire de son peuplement que cette
situation presque inédite donc un
endroit qui a vu affluer les gens qui
fuyaient l'administration coloniale et
qui fuyait les mettre pour faire
l'expérience de la liberté dans un
endroit qui paradoxalement est une
prison minérale et donc j'ai vu une
utopie et le sujet m'intéressait et
c'est à partir de cette idée là que j'ai
développé l'écriture de mon fils lorsque
je vais vous dire porte pour ce qui est
des décors salazie et cilaos c'est aussi
bien oui oui enfin effectivement jeu
pour être tout à fait honnête avec avec
vous et les auditeurs tous les tous les
plans n'ont pas été tournées à mafate
quand quand on avait besoin de férin un
extérieur forêt j'ai pas déplacé toute
une équipe parce que si on avait un
budget assez limité donc on garde nos
héros c'est ça oui voilà c'était
difficile de trouver de l'argent
oui ça a été assez difficile enfin il
faut il faut il faut il faut concourir à
toutes les aides évidemment j'ai été
aidé par la région j'ai été aidé par le
cnc aussi vous avez puisé dans vos
données personnelles
oui je dois beaucoup
oui j'ai dépensé un peu toutes mes
économies pour m'équiper en caméra etc
alors vous avez tout fait pour ce film
vous avez écrit vous avez fait le
casting c'est épuisant c'est beaucoup
dire je voudrais rendre rendre
un hommage aussi aux gens qui m'ont aidé
parfois de manière bénévole donc à
bubble fish qui est une jeune société
qui fait de la réalité virtuelle dans
les locaux de pipangaï par exemple
fallait faire aussi m'a soutenu mais
c'est vrai que j'ai dû assumer la
plupart des rôles donc j'étais chef
opérateur j'ai enfin j'étais aussi des
facteurs d'acteur c'est moi qui fais le
casting c'est moi qui fais le montage
c'est moi qui fais les d'élevage will
fall images wii alors justement à voir
revenir donc sur ce film jeunes mafate
et
qui donc un peu un marginal hi-fi dans
son coin dans sa cabane est un peu
regardés de travers par les autres et
puis bon on va pas tout dire il arrive
quelque chose à un moment et est obligé
de partir et puis il fuit son lieu
magique là où il vit en tous les cas
pour lui paisiblement et varrault
retrouver j'allais dire les la côte là
où on vit autrement puisque c'est un
contraste complètement saisissant entre
les deux mondes oui et pour qu est-ce
que vous avez montré que vous même vivre
dans mafate cueilli sur la côte
à cécile questions compliquées non pour
moi enfin bien que n'étant pas natif de
lille 2 est arrivé en quelle année quand
même je suis allé en
2017 oui ok bon allez enfin vous
connaissez bien lu vous avez nous
montrer quoique lancé mieux mafate ah
non non non pour moi en tant qu'auteur
je me suis emparé d'eux deux sets de
cette thématique parce que parce que
pour moi femme a fait c'est un lieu un
peu préservé du temps et donc j'ai voulu
c'est un film sur la perte des illusions
enfin mon personnage est quelqu'un
d'assez jeunes qui a été préservé et
puis qui tout d'un coup pas se demande à
l'autre d'un monde à l'autre voilà qui
découvre et qui découvre comme l'enfant
découvre la trentaine il met la
civilisation gemini politique mais un
délire ben ce qui n'est pas ma fat coi
c'est à dire la rumeur le bruit le vol
qui va connaître et puis va être
confronté ben il va devenir bas puisque
marginale parce qu'elle devenir eux
mêmes voleurs oui il faut passer par là
pour pouvoir survivre à report
en tout cas c'est le sait le sait le
parcours de mon personnage quoi oui va
il va un petit peu s'est brûlé les ailes
qui est confronté à l'amour est très
conduit et puis aussi l'amour la mort
l'amour la mort l'amour l'amour le mal
le mal c'est ça
qu'est ce qui compte quand vous avez
fait pour trouver vos acteurs haut ce
que bon en dehors d'un que je connais
personnellement fava personnellement que
c'est qui est donc le motard face lui
rendra pas moins quoi mais les hommes
ont été trouvés vous avez trouvé ce
jeune homme dans deux jours dont j'ai
oublié le nom mais dont maurice
l'allemande a récemment vous avez trouvé
pour isla de mort parce que il
intervient de ce personnage un peu
mystérieux
j'allais dire un peu sauvage
alors boris je les trouvais à l'institut
de l'image de l'océan indien où je au
port où j'enseigne en fait il est je
m'étais engagé avec un autre comédien
puis finalement ça n'a pas fonctionné et
j'ai été agrément enfin agréablement
surpris quand j'ai entraperçu ce jeune
homme que je trouve très sculptural
quelque chose presque de la statuaire
antique et je trouve que ça enfin et me
suis tout de suite dit qui servirait
bien enfin justement le le propos de ce
film qui est presque une tragédie
puisque les chaussons annoncé dès le
départ par un prédicateur dans la forêt
etc donc voila et puis mais c'est vrai
que c'est très compliqué qu'il ya peu
d'acteurs professionnels en tout cas
d'acteurs de cinéma il ya des acteurs de
théâtre mais les actes ordinaires ne
sont pas forcément grand acteur au
cinéma et j'avais le souci aussi de
faire un film naturaliste donc il
fallait que je trouve des des personnes
des personnages vrais qu'ils n'aient pas
besoin d'interpréter mais qui pouvait
incarner son
qui pouvait incarner faire les
personnages que j'avais imaginé et donc
basse et des déambulations dans la rue
si je m'arrête en trombe sur un trottoir
et je demande et je demande enfin
quelqu'un à sa grande surprise s'il veut
pas jouer le soir un film
alors donc c'était triste en créole il
faut le dire était sous titrage soit en
france est sûre d'encaisser en allemand
selon les pays où ça va être diffusé et
mais il ya pour moi il ya un contraste
entre le créole décès de la jeune fille
qui va rencontrer et les pêcheurs qui me
semble tout à fait authentique fois pour
moi c'est voulu j'ai pas dire cette
différence de créole mais je trouve que
nos fans de la jeune fille beaucoup plus
francisé peut-être parce que justement
elles veulent elles valaient en
métropole
oui oui peut-être que c'est un
personnage effectivement si elle
consciente watts par mais peut-être que
ces inconscients ou en tout cas c'est
une chance parce que finalement ça sert
bien le film que cette jeune fille va
effectivement et est déjà
fin sur le point de partir et peut-être
plus plus plus modernes afin que le que
le pêcheur qui incarne peut-être une
union plus plus plus ancestrales heigl
qui vous pose me remettez vous en face
du micro n'y aille pas pourquoi le
créole est ce que ça ne risque pas de
freiner la diffusion du film home est de
toute façon je fais un film à la réunion
les gens parlent créole donc moi dans un
souci naturaliste je ne pouvais que
dialoguer mon film en créole comme
emmanuel parot dans un sac la mort comme
emmanuel qui a opté aussi pour cette
version là alors donc cesser
ces comédiens sont tous des amateurs
enfin c'est comme aider ces acteurs sont
tous des amateurs oui c'était compliqué
c'était difficile ou alors en c'est
devenu naturellement pour certains ça a
été très compliqué ça a été très
compliqué de les trouver par exemple
justement le pêcheur qui est absolument
extraordinaire
enfin on l'appelle grand jones et signe
c'est une légende selon l'insee 1
cordistes c'est un colosse dans la vie
wihda bank et d'autres femmes beaucoup
de gens falconnet c'est vraiment un
personnage encore at il est pour toi je
sais pas il est un peu sur toute l'île a
pas de domicile fixe
la fille à l'image du marché oui enfin
il ya beaucoup de copines donc ils
voyagent
donc c'est un cordistes c'est quelqu'un
qui appeler quand il s'agit par exemple
de casser des jardinières 30 mètres du
sol avec avec un marteau piqueur de 40
kg il ya que lui qui peut le faire parce
que c'est vraiment si si c'est un
colosse et donc ses grands john cox john
je les ai trouvés
razar un peu par hasard j'ai chez un ami
fin j'avais été boire un verre puis je
me suis arrêté sur les pieds de cet
homme ses mains waouh c'est le son
visage je me suis dit waouh et j'ai dû
aller le chercher la veille du tournage
sur un chantier il me donnait pas signe
de vie tout le monde femme avait dîné à
temps mais c'est un punk que c'est
impossible si c'est impossible de le
gérer et effectivement enfin il a fallu
aller chercher à saint pierre est moins
grand john complètement beau et très fin
le soir même parce qu'il doit pas vous
même fait le matin même parce qu'ils
tournaient dans la journée mais on y
arriver et
je regrette rien parce que vraiment ce
personnage là extraordinaire ils sont
présents il fait j'ai vu qu'il avait des
jambes axa monte dans les rois maudits
chanteur voilà là alors ce film il sort
alors c'est bien au ritz et or est fixé
au ray et au rex à partir du 30 mai
jusqu'au 5 juin et c'est armand tofan
kiwis qui vous qui vous pilote sa
vendeuse écouter ah oui j'imagine parce
qu'il faut savoir ce qu'on va dire de ce
film or vous êtes prêt à en refaire un
autre je crois que c'est on me jeter
quelque chose
baboo les donc j'ai rencontré mes
producteurs qui m'ont suivi dans cette
aventure qui sont assez contents qu'ils
aiment beaucoup le film et donc ils sont
prêts à me suivre dans le projet suivant
qui cette fois ci se passera entre
liberia en italie les baux de provence
et l'erythrée donc je change pas la
bouger beaucoup là bas donc défini sera
en français cette fois ci sera en
français en italien et se disent
confiants tigrine à cardy gré d'accord
ok mais un titre est encore bien sûr
alors par trois semaines le film sera la
fiche dans ses deux salles c'est bien et
ensuite qu'est-ce qui se passe cannes
l'année prochaine
europe 1 on l'a présenté en fait pour
cette édition ci fait les producteurs
l'ont présenté il est resté dans la
short list donc les 100 derniers films
et puis finalement il n'a pas été pris
bon mais c'est vrai que c'est assez
compliqué parce que c'est un film qui
fait 53 minutes donc les festivals de
courts métrages demande moins de 30
minutes les festivals de long on demande
plus plus de plus d'une heure donc ça
fonctionne un peu au coup de coeur alors
il a été sélectionné au film il est
inscrit dans des festivals
internationaux
et puis j'espère faire une télé pourquoi
pas
france ô voilà il a été sélectionné aux
familles qui est un festival le plus
grand festival de l'outre-mer
j'espère que ça ça aidera le film à être
diffusés en télé pour pour toucher le
plus de gens possible quand on est assis
vous n'êtes pas sélectionné pour cannes
cette année antoine c'est peut-être pour
le second film nous espérions voilà en
tout cas vous souhaite bonne chance je
rappelle le titre du film de mafate et
avec je sais pas s'il faut dire que
c'est un sous titre c'est marqué sur la
fiche l'odyssée du ma fat et du sommet
des montagnes battant des lames c'est
une expression qu'on aime bien à la
réunion 1 depuis qu elle a été reprise
par comment s'appelle encore catherine
lavaud rop auto iv et navo puisque je
l'espère on n'est pas des nains je sais
et ça colle bien avec votre film il
descend de la montagne jusqu'au sommet
et oui la mer il connaît bien dans ce
film merci olivier jeanne et emmanuel
parot merci olivier carette mafieux vous
écoutez sa réponse
[Musique]
oui
et perdent dans la
naeem divine à genève m
[Musique]
pour vivre là bas
défaut courant
jason au plus haut
tu kazan 2
mais on essai
me comprends
la faim dans les mains
[Musique]
batta
nous enfermer
[Musique]
et
nous enfants
[Musique]
nous
et
quand même
malheureux de l'eau
or
[Musique]
aussant
karassine
[Musique]
mais je reste le cas
pour féminin
d'autres choses
pour manger
là
300 millions
chose tout fait
les knicks un passe temps
à metz dinan
nous envoler
[Musique]
le
nous a pas toujours
aussi disert
[Musique]
un jeu
nous entoure
boussois a toujours
voici misère
nous
nous envoler
un jour mon dieu j'adore la lumière
nous en parler
[Musique]
les chenilles public aux enfants nés aux
chansons écrit par christian baptisto
qui date de 1981 vous la connaissez
olives etc arrestations sont je le
connaissais je faisais je connaissais
pas l'auteur mais je connaissais la
chanson hard en plus qui s'abattent
historique habite dans le sud je sais
pas si vous habitez dans le sud mais
c'est un sudiste aujourd'hui après avoir
vécu longtemps dans le nord est à peu
près en fait il n'y a pas beaucoup de
musique parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
musique seront dans votre film non non
c'est vrai nom s'était plaint un choix
délibéré je voulais faire quelque chose
de très très sec parce que bien souvent
enfin la musique accompagne faire les
émotions et peut-être les forces un
petit peu donc je il faut être en quatre
minutes pratiquement avant qu'on entende
quelqu'un parler dans votre film pendant
quatre minutes il n'y a que des images
et des mouvements de caméra oui dans la
première partie est impressionniste puis
elle expose un peu la situation du
personnage principal et puis on rentre
dans le récit après effectivement cinq
minutes alors de contemplation en
revanche vous êtes alors pas rendre
compte en passant vous vous êtes fait
plaisir à les images de paysages alors
ça vous vous êtes de nuit comme de jour
vous à vous êtes servis à volonté un oui
vous êtes suis vraiment fait plaisir là
oui ben moi je viens l'image vient de la
photo donc j'avais aussi à coeur de
faire l'image puis le 2 de photographier
fin lors ils n'y ont pas dû américaine
aussi s'il ya une nuée américaine
le discours du prédicateur quand le
quand quand les mafatais qui tu quittes
le cirque à ces numérique d'accord entre
l'état merci merci à vous
culture premières poésies à présent avec
vous une idée rancourt bonsoir pour ça
une soirée qui a lieu ce mardi 29 à
champ fleuri dans la salle carreaux
quand une petite salle 200 personnes
salle intimiste avec vous gérald coupama
et patrick sida vous vous d'éclat mais
alors qu'est ce qu'ils font les autres
gérald silva des cas mais parce que
gerald c'est un comédien danseur
il va il va dire d'un policier également
et patrick est bien le grand musicien
patrick sida jour alors qu'il ya eu
cette idée de dans mon sous big dan s
appliquer à la lettre l'adage qui sonne
verdâtre la dette du groupe folklorique
de la réunion et c'est une c'est un
concept en coréalisation avec les
théâtres départementaux de la réunion
quand vous avez été choisie se tenait
penser puisque vous connaissent un coup
de coeur c'est quoi qu'est-ce qui a fait
que cette fois ci on a mis la poésie
vous avez quoi vous savez non l'année
dernière oui oui oui il y avait pas tout
le mime le même bateau il y avait aussi
que je réfléchisse jeu régis sakai et
roger carr pa le meut trompettiste par
la
connaissez
olivier caract
brozek arpin la régie sakai non ça vous
dit rien me régis l'accueil le n'ont pas
tous la fin je le connais parce qu'il
est parce que parce qu'il a fait des
interventions à l'institut de l'image
j'avais un personnage alors donc verser
cette année elle est venu vous voir oui
enfin c'est l'année dernière qui a pris
contact est ce qu il faut préparer le
programme est bien c'est un cadeau bon
dieu jean paul ii boudou oui mais là
rien demandé et puis un jour de la dette
rappelle annie voile a décidé en accord
bien entendu avec pascal montrouge que
me salue et que mir vinci bain de fin de
soirée de poésie avec
qu'avec ou gerald et avec patrick sida
bien sûr il ya de mon écoute la poésie
mais il suffit de voir les kabars fonker
et puis ben si mystérieux reste plus
grand place
deux filles de nombreux
l'extrait la grande surprise de la
grande joie aussi comme quoi la poésie
banalement nième la police alors un
scoop une différence au haut de la
poésie le fond de coeur
annoncé la même chose
le
candide le cabba fonken tout est décidé
d'un long et voilà les
indiens poèmes aller lot et d'actuariat
la pad l'a pas tellement de prépa icônes
et carbon un tel un thalys à dire mais
voilà c'est ça ce pet de l'entourage
pintade d'accord de votre subitement du
sud ont faune qui oppose
les deux leaders pour moi c'est la même
chose on ne crée en france et peut y
entrer ok mais moi me trouve avec moi me
trouveront tous les corps que ne l'a
fait les gars y sommes c'est que comme
la bonne jeunes et islam est le score
c'est quoi c'est de la poésie seulement
pour moi mais a remis peu trompé mais
tant mieux parce qu'il permet bonne
maman écrire exactement oui oui et puis
d'avec avec de la musique rap et slam la
musique va là dessus et mais l'important
c'est les mots
les super la première fois on a assisté
à un festival de poésie en 2001 maurice
avec des slameurs à a été ne connaissez
pas le slam l'a découvert le slam est
ensuite en 2003 l'a fait lui dit elle a
fait le premier festival de poésie et
celles avec les doigts avec stéphane à
de keating de l'île maurice les venus
emmener le slam à la réunion ça fait un
tabac dans les écoles et à la rescousse
l'amour elles n'ont
pas d'âge pour cela mais
il préfère que c'était comme dans l'otan
mais habitués monaco alors que ça quand
ça se présente comme poésie comme poèmes
qui s'appelle otto 90 alors qu'elle se
tienne un art banana alors les auteurs
de bons de la réunion blé blé plus
connus enfin les plus connus en fait de
la dette la pacha thanou 10 sacs de m ok
ça fonctionne peace and aliens entre
autres causes connaît un bon peut vous
être mis un bon nanar non mais ce soir
là
m'ont dit ce mardi soir alors n'aura un
texte de gilbert aubry d'un à
jean-françois samlong dans la des textes
d'alain oren
de albanie peters
nana sully andoche des jeunes des plus
jeunes des plus intuitives oui oui parce
que bombardier bear aubry s'cusez moi
gilbert aubry allait leur aide quand
même bienvenu à la lorraine est même
passé à côté bon
[Rires]
eh bah écoute non
non mais attends
jean-paul
l'indiana donc c'est des poèmes que bon
nous portons nous portons depuis des
années mais attention noonan a des
jeunes poètes là c'est ça me faisait ce
qui dénote d'une jeune génération eu mon
aval à
compass deux autres mardi soir
n'est pas compliqué qui recensera moungo
non non non non non non non parce que
les textes là que les choisit gerald et
moi nous les dents dans ce moment d'art
dans le ponde coeur la poésie depuis
1980 dont cannes à des textes que nous
connaît déjà que les plus faciles parce
que c'est une soirée quand même hein
c'est à peu près dix poèmes chacun donc
on est à la fois mémorisées ouais et la
vieillerie s'installe la vieillerie
c'est après la jeunesse avant la
vieillesse tu vois mais déjà l'âge de la
vieillerie donc
tu vois déjà là l'appréhension d'avoir
bombardé des trous ce soit là alors donc
à l'aide à prendre d'autres textes nous
ont mis la salle pour les autres mais il
ya la géniale de la nouvelle génération
de de deux poètes nana erika maso sokolo
caf gousse lie tous ses représentants
ben écoute
oui fin d'émission banive bien et
c'était pas pour reprendre le mot de
passe reste retard la phrase de patrice
très tard c'est des petits frères qui
lève la génération en fond de coeur en
poésie
vont aller là pour moi fond de
compositions et peut-être même à un peu
il dit
j'accepte gérance
patrick sida dans le guitariste inconnus
à abyei qu'il y avait fondé fait des
deux cdc me trompe pas moi la lune un
groupe qui appelle le jo célimène avec
ta victoire alors que ça défoule il
attend pas très haut c'est alors il ya
des certains poèmes l'uv accompagnant
nos un petit peu monde est petit et qui
dénote d'un tournage de questions si
vous voulez ne connut alors dallas
derrière mais il va intervenir avec ses
propres compositions composition des
compositions son frère
a
pas de réponse non parce que alors tu
connais ce matin de la travailler le
temps répétition la haute est un donc en
fonction des poèmes l'écoutent et c'est
après voilà lui va choisir en fonction
du poème et cetera ceux qui aspirent à
lisses que le var ce que levadia dont la
méconnaît pas ce qu'il va jouer
l'improvisation est venu dans tous les
cas de laporte patrick parce que présent
peu bon tout d'un coup il y avait des
sites fait ça et puis peut-être que ce
soit là l'inspiration dit autrement les
richesses que nous n'ayons pas
d'improvisation oui oui oui oui oui le
poème voilà ce qu'on nous a demandé ali
donc tu banon l'adieu là où en temps là
où en train d'écouter aurait maintenant
tu l'as dans lequel a fait pour s'en
aller coûte doit codem baladons cra de
l'improvisation oui combien de temps la
danse aura duré une heure et demie 8h08
heure le soir 20h 21h30 alors que mon
sens où là à quelques heures ou jours
plus tôt
quelques jours ci médias ou my déjà
malade cra
oui
je râle quand je rentre pas mais j'ai
râlé dit pas je râle il connaît son
texte carrillo scène gerald il connaît
plus tu vois c'est ça aussi c'est que
nous travaillons gerald vont
régulièrement les soit bien la maison ne
travaillent pas ce que nana des textes
gérant tout ça tout seul et un add texte
ou celle de tu vas voilà et nous donc
nous travailler à ça et puis un bal des
moments ce matin gerald il connaît plus
rien rien du passé
alors qu'il ya soit
les textes que dans français et en
créole dans les deux ce coin là les deux
nanas les deux français créole par
santana dépôt voilà pour si tu veux eh
bien on a des poètes que l'on entend
plus est-ce que
julien n'a grains qui alias pierre
chassagne que ça l'est devenu ne connaît
pas jean claude télé ou wii
ne connaît pas que c'est devenu des
nanas des poètes comme ça ne connais pas
donc c'est l'occasion aussi de bain
ainsi dominicaux les votes de dire que
ces personnes allaient créer un moment
donné quoi la fédé joli texte a
peut-être que ce sera l'occasion un jour
de faire une soirée poésie avec des noms
un peu moins connus parce que là
la lorraine et cpt inconnue peut-être
que faire connaître la jeune génération
ce beau monde arabe et bien sûr bien sûr
ouais entièrement d'accord entièrement
d'accord avec vous mais la voix comme
l'affirmé un cadeau quant au bon dieu
voilà je me refuse pas et puis bon bain
à d'autres occasions bah oui moi même
beaucoup me savard à ces soirées de
poésie découvert les textes de ses
petits frères label rennais n'a des
jeunes 20 des jeunes dans la dans la de
jeunes munis vient écouter de la poésie
ou alors il n'a rien vieux moun nan nan
un jeune mouna nana na na na bien plus
de jeunes que nous que nous croyons qu
voilà que non la poésie dit la poésie
n'est pas aimer si la poésie mais la
seule chose qu'on regarde et comment
dans les écoles il ya des conquois la
fête des mères la demande en effet les
petits poèmes vous êtes maman la radio
enfin poèmes en haïti même la fête de
l'école si ya bien poésie olivia
carretera là où la poésie
je pense je pense que le cruel farine
mais une langue déjà de politique parce
qu elle parce que c'est une langue
imagée et puis oui oui très sensible
très sensible à la poésie c'est
d'ailleurs ce que j'ai essayé de faire
dans mon film c'est de faire de la
poésie avec avec les images faire des
associations comme ça qu'ils produisent
du sens enfin les associations je pense
par exemple au chien
chien famille c'est vrai
que voilà associés faire des choses
qu'ils produisent un sens qui ne soit
pas
univoque quoi mais qui l'ex femme l'oeuf
à l'imagination faut aussi interprété
fin librement de potes de l'image
si tu veux c'est que committee c'est un
dg râle nous les relâche de la
vieillerie ne veux plus te fais trop les
feuilles puis le dic stéviol elle a peu
saturé donc nous apprend des textes il
ya des années que la génération de
maintenant il connaît pas mais dans les
années 80 4 85 86 alemany lorraine
et détecte jusqu'à quand par exemple
pourquoi pas puisque titre talent qui
détestent plus qu'à gérer
gilles bel écrin magnifique texte à kuta
coup absolument seul petit livret vert
il faut vous trouverez qui était la
préface du livre d'albert bébé à la
migration réunionnais c'est que milow
cazères de dire plusieurs fois et qui
une fois nana des années de cela à
l'occasion d'une émission serait nos
premières avec de nick lui goûté aux
halles et nous la maladie ce poème qui
avait
inspiré un directeur d'une société pour
mettre ce poème dans la société parce
que c'est une société
de2
d'assistance voilà raconte man 2
personnes à lutter encore avant nous
kitano ou peu le
poisson alors de mémoire un nouveau
déboire alors on a choisi
un poème d'alain peters que l'a jamais
été mis en musique bien pas ma
connaissance en avait parlé avec sa
soeur samassa et vaquer manuelles et
jeux voilà un nom emmanuel c'est pas ça
je mets les en haut de sa jumelle
d'accord et ananda devi et cette chanson
là n'a jamais été mis en musique
peut-être peut-être espiranencs joie
mettre en musique y appelle sans toi du
coup comme dit coluche c'est comme ça
c'est la théorie théo était d'accord ok
c'est pas que les rhodes par vaux par
mots mais quand les voies les hôtes en
fait pas besoin de croire à l'idée
mousse il vient rôder 3 miettes la frime
et 600 go nous l'apprennent de classe
politique y est les hawks bien au chaud
dans un nid va dire nous place nous n'y
achète quand on y arrive pas ce dessert
cet acquis pommes poires ou la crème bon
dieu sans toi à quoi il sert nalgon bien
amer son carême nana plein comme lui
dans la rue mais la chance et l'epasa
clottes
si chacun ira leçon charrues sac
certains quand même plus loin se dote
peut-être la mort avec son h camdessus
le couteau qui tombe la vie ou donne ou
iard h
va mettre le bonheur dans son ton alors
alain peters ouais pourquoi quand il
était vivant personne ne parlait
pratiquement pas de lui et depuis qu'il
est mort alors là c'est la révélation
parce que nous il venait souvent à
l'époque chez nous sur 20 fr3 rfo on l'a
vu et puis on a découvert que c'était un
poète c'était un musicien car avec un
talent immense
jean-paul ne pourra pas y répondent à ou
vraiment mais moi alain madelin - les
mangas et chaudron était voilée tout le
temps jeune chaux-de-fonnier mal avait
vu alain allen avait peut-être 19 20 ans
mois l'avait 13 14 ans quand ils savent
à l'école tu es voix alain qu'avait déjà
la queue de cheval à cette époque-là
révolutionnaire révolutionnaire beau
garçon tu attendes mascotte abbas coffre
qui vivait en france comme une oeuvre à
la délicate ont deux mascottes et selon
son l'endroit était là où ça maintenant
un à coller chaudron voilà émois
adolescents 13 14 ans avale école
collège
n'était pas encore le bus tous les
collèges saint clotilde est bien quand
nous parce nous voit alain nous tuer
sparrow gardannais c'est un garçon trop
beau trop ne te connais le musicien
voilà c'était déjà notre idole netheos
pas regarder voit donc
et par la poésie de ce second texte
découvert vers quel âge à bas depuis
mangez pas le cas depuis le livre l
assentiment j'ai mangé pas le coeur
sentir la der
l'association
des écrivains de la réunion qui était
fondée par kid allechi oui alain g leca
disparu de la circulation du reste n'ont
alors fait longtemps que j'ai pas vu mme
bah oui enfin il était tantôt ici tantôt
il va ressembler à demi-mot kampala il
pas si bien
les à amiens à l'accueil du festival
d'amiens aa et justement fois cette
année il a là il a réussi à mettre en
place une une série de projections de
films réunionnais a bien accéléré ses
contacts et ses mais on va bien rigoler
père c'est lui qui a sorti ses dires
avec la der ce qu'elle y a il ya albanie
et tantine ça ça oui en foot aussi alors
on essaie désespérément d'avoir notre
troisième éviter pour nous parler de
génération à la gamme le technicien me
fait signe que malheureusement il ne
répond pas il m'avait prévenu qu'il
était en conférence de presse ce soir
pour annoncer donc la soirée de samedi
mais qui ferait le nécessaire pour se
libérer mon apparemment il n'est pas pu
faire on va continuer quand même à
parler poésie avec annie drancourt alors
année est ce que mes plus de monaco et
votre poème où ils exagèrent
alors que mais voulait dire aussi des
auditeurs de réunion 1ère toutes les là
parce qu'elles en fassent aussi pascal
et l'autre côté là là fini ferman grâce
à lui qu'on arrive et c'est
aura aussi des textes de daniel nourry a
common gramoune et sully andoche ces
deux bonhommes là les plus connus qu'en
dis tu en voilà voilà mais voilà ce
qu'écrit aussi et c'est l'occasion de
dire que cette nana d'autres encore oui
mais dany
boon est moins connu mais les vrais que
les les compteurs et qui lui fait
beaucoup pour le compte porter nuit
formation de formation histoire ça dans
mon frère daniel est la montre hermès
exactement
non non c'est gerald qui qui dit alors
que celle du alors que ça me sady un
note de nos grandes banques ce qu'on
note 2006 les manèges de la terre de mon
grand frère patrice treuthardt le envol
du maître des kabars diseurs de mots
sorcier gardons cette parole en mémoire
je parle de la parole est essentielle
d'une saison de grande abondance de
parole d'une lame de fond d'un fond de
l'âme d'un accès à la plus haute
conditions je parle de la parole est
essentielle capable de sauver mon âme
décati je parle de la parole retrouvée
sans commencement est sans fin neuf fois
plus douce que le miel deux fois plus
amer aussi dû mettre des kabars diseurs
de mots sorcier gardons cette parole en
mémoire le miracle est en nous ayo
matelots la poésie est en nous mocky
raclant l'âme de grandfonds wayuu auquel
plus grand exil dis-je ne point écouté
en pleine désobéissance du poème tempo
vois-tu sont comme des oeufs est clos
ils sont des ailes parole lavandières
des varices de la terre heureusement à
décaper n'importe quel masque à
mascarades de masques en mascareignes
lille rené de mon grain de folie du
maître des kabars diseurs de mots
sorcier gardons cette parole en mémoire
la poésie est un outil pour aggraver
notre identité
c'est un hommage en taux de cas à la
réunion un bel hommage à la réunion tous
les cas enfin à la langue aussi à la mls
est écrit en français oui le plus comme
quoi
bien sûr non tout le temps les 10 soit
par cause nous qu est ce qu on sait que
les contes créoles nous défendre le
creal que les comptes le français et ça
va pas pour autant nier pâques aux
français bon voilà
dans tous les cas ali donc gerald
coupama
attaque sida à au mardi 29 donne car
aucun
sens parce que c'est un petit peu ma
place donc si de motiver le niveau
résonne alors n'hésite pas
à 20 heures vas-tu arrêté il commence
vingtaine fini 21e mais parfois ça
non non je ne peux plus non il fait un
petit peu plus oui mais commence pas en
retard
d'abord parce que ça la réunion ce trop
souvent les mêmes dates et comment
certains métaux cette détestable pas
d'impôts les gens qu'il arrivait à
l'heure est à faire attendre et puis
pour une artiste aussi que les peut-être
prêt et que l'objet d'attentes de moins
que les retards dans les cas merci
olivier merci merci
c'est la fin de deux pas des célèbres
donne au sein des noms de culture
première 18h58